[Applause]
as you may already have heard we are
about to be
invaded trillions of insects will emerge
from the ground in some of the most
populated parts of the country
they're called cicadas and every 17
years
massive swarms appear in 15 states
from georgia to eastern illinois they
can be as loud
as a lawnmower ben tracy is in what
could be one of the hottest hot spots
washington d.c ben are you ready
no i am not ready at all i'm looking for
a place to hide because we are expecting
up to 1.5 million cicadas
per acre in some places like this this
is rock creek park
in the middle of washington dc and in a
couple of days you're going to see these
bugs crawling up trees like this one
and once they do come out they have just
one thing on their minds
they are creepy and they are crawly with
a face
only an entomologist could love i'm an
entomologist
i'm living the dream that all
entomologists get to live
sammy ramsey studies insects at the u.s
department of agriculture
they call me dr bugs dr buzz
he was just a bug-loving
fourteen-year-old the last time these
seventeen-year cicadas
came out to play the official name for
this species
is magicicada septum dessen
and it's it specifically means the
magical cicada that emerges every 17
years
for some it's less magic more nightmare
the cicadas are everywhere
and they are loud the males
are the really loud ones and that's
their way of saying
i'm ready to hook up i'm ready for love
all they want to do is mate
and have babies they live fast and
really enjoy themselves at this point
so this is like insect spring break oh
yes you can't blame them
these cicadas have been stuck
underground eating tree roots since 2004
back then george w bush was running for
re-election
i accept your nomination for president
iphones didn't exist and usher ushered
in that spring's
insect invasion this is the big daddy of
the 17 year cicadas
floyd shockley oversees the national
cicada collection at the smithsonian
museum
of natural history so these are
periodical cicadas you see here
he says brood 10 is one of the largest
and most dense population of cicadas
in the world magic cicada is only found
here in the eastern u.s
nowhere else in the world and no other
cicadas
have a 17-year life cycle
scientists believe cicadas may actually
use the annual changes in tree samp they
feed on underground
to tell time they count okay that's one
more
that's one more that's one more until
they hit 17 and then up they come
so these things are smarter than they
look uh i would certainly think that but
imagine if your big day
you guys should be married by now right
correct
collides with the cicadas big year we
were running
right into the next issue ben harris and
taya hyman plan to get married in ohio
last summer
kovid cancelled that when did you guys
first realize
there might be a problem this summer
i was talking to my mom and she was like
you know it feels like it's been a
really long time since the 17 years
cicadas came out
the couple was so worried they called
this ohio entomologist
gene kritsky who has his own tracking
app called cicada safari
he told them the bug should be gone in
time for their july third
outdoor wedding he also let us know that
cicadas are very romantic so they're not
the worst thing to happen to a wedding
dr bugs agrees that romantic is a nice
way of looking at it i'm hoping that we
might be able to tweak our thinking
about these creatures a bit
remember that they are lonely organisms
who have dwelled in isolation for far
too long
and be able to connect with them i think
a little less connecting more avoiding
for me but here's the good news cicadas
do not sting they do not bite
they are harmless to humans and gail
you're going to want to hear this
uh some people do actually eat cicadas
there are cookbooks i can send you one
if you'd like one yes have we met ben
does that sound like something i want to
do
yeah but i love your story i love doctor
you had so many good elements i love the
couple that was great thank you thank
you
and i learned something i just assumed
that cicadas sting
yeah i just assumed that but they don't
they look scary
uh i don't know it looks scary romantic
lonely romantic creatures
sympathetic view of the cicada i like
that inside i have a good spring break
very nice